foreign
the number one pick for the
Maple Leafs win battles for
foxy gets caught that incredible crazy wrist shot
six times a 30 goal scorer and here's a turnover
to chance scores and the only player to be playing
in back-to-back games Ruby you're bitty as
the Icebreaker here at 116 of the first period
once the puck turns over everyone's leaving
the Zone it's so much the NHL now here's
Gannett shooting it that's knocked down and
a lead feed here's coward with a break he's
the cow and stop penalty coming up
and it's going to be a penalty shot
so it's eastern count against Matt so guard as
the youngster whoops the tide for Maple Leafs
and stopped on a ring pad saved by silkard
stick side and we know Soul guard such a big
guy and those are big flippers he's got down
on the ice he almost faded him he gave him a
little shoulder shrug as he got to the hash
marks and soul guard looked like he was going
to bite on it but he didn't he was patient
looked like he was gonna drop right there
here's Shabbat on the right side and that's been
a talking point in Ottawa chicken and Shabbat
switching sides Luke and there's your pinti on
it again looking to center it it'll come back to
Tops and fire against scores plus he tops it with
the shot did kubilee get a touch it's two-nothing
Ottawa but I think you're right CC I think
kubilee gets this one Lassie Thompson could
really bring it and he's got a real heater the
five goals that were scored were all perfect to
having a guy Campbell right in front of the net
there's no way that they'll lean towards the half
walls and they'll leave that shooter open comes
Gregor with a burst to speed Amber's easy into
the slot hits Kickback to nebula now they won't
defense but never sees he now [Applause] [Music]
a first group how about that power plays
all about good skating getting in the end
is Gregor and he has a real big factor
in this goal you know you've got Cowan
in the middle in the slot they're
all in the right position [Applause]
downlink trying to jam it in and gubalik
comes close to his second instead you know
you're new on a team he's making passes he is
a shooter I was surprised you didn't unload
that got it to Matthews it must swap did
Robertson let that fly so guard with the
stops of back across Tarasenko fumbles
that matherson taken out by Giordano
David camp in a battle back to shabbat chicken
scores what a rocket by Jacob chicken and it's
a two goal Ottawa lead once again towards the
point before he puts him back there is super
important he gets in here right back to the point
and that creates space for Shabbat to get the
puck turn around and get it to Chickering if he
skates up the wall just two or three steps that
pass to shabbat is not there instead it's low to
high I really believe their power play will be up
in the top five this year I I do believe that if
Norris is healthy I think that is a possibility
because we're fire across they were eight last
year that shot deflected in Indiana [Applause]
Joseph blandeezy with the deflection turned
around boom up the middle so he's on his game
there tonight nice job on the four check by
blandeezy he goes in he creates an open for
the puck to get turned over and then he goes
good things happen that's not always pretty and
the shock to the net is a bit high and it rattles
off a couple of people then finally into the net
get one here late in the first period 27 seconds
after the chicken power play goal the least hit
back to within one 16-50 the time of the goal
for playing dizzy and a chance there for Joseph
and stop by wall Shabbat and chicken
are back there on the E unit there's
chicken moving it again back
door comes across can't catch
so guard
he's supposed to shrink so he starts the second
period Ottawa is on the power played 15 shots
credited to the senators or Shabbat karaoke
now shy about firing it the metal Ricochet
back out to Center as klingberg returns to the
ice here's a steal a chance for Nick Robertson
and it's home stopped by soguard looked pretty
good yesterday I don't know if I'd want to mess
with that line with Drew yep there's Reiner
to the minute the dangerous Dash and rolled
down and able to keep it out that was a Nifty
piece of work stepped onto the ice try to get
it back and does and now with control 34 a crowd
straight pass barter and he can't slide under your
Zone guard you don't want to goal he gives you
gray hair that's for sure there's a difference
the post back the other way it's Matthew
Joseph with your Betsy going to the Nets
Joseph him deep trying to center
it Jones down and he'll cover up
firstly Drake digs in on this Face-Off against
Austin Matthews and from the drop Martin Jones had
to be sharp on that shot and another goes down and
unable to cover up it will come loose for Shabbat
serious stuff and uh big top tip
of the cap to Sean that's awesome
appreciate it I am one and done no more for me
that's it like still be a Kitchener Ranger young
defenseman out on the ice here as it's passed
across Robertson backhand did that stop by Soaker
loose in front you want to take a point away from
Young Easton Cowan on a make the way he's playing
but it has been reinstated there's a shot host
but not in what a blast that was he loved to
see the skating the net drive and we'd like to
see him find a way to get him and soul guard
is good for it and Matthews wins another draw
a dozen seconds to go clean Burger cross down
low it goes Matthews playing Bird shooting if
[Applause] [Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
and when it hits him it drops over and couldn't
escape to the stick and that is the power play
in a six on four with the goalie pull
for the Toronto Maple Leafs nine Power
Play Goals for Martin last Jerry has a game
time goal here in the preseason at 1954. yeah
in a gratuitous bounce onto the skate
of Marner who puts it to his stick and
deposits it in the back of the net now we
got a little three-on-three action here
Austin Matthews gets control for the leaps that's
his 18th Face-Off win of the game back for Shabbat
Kirk shank knocked off his stick following up
and there's another post Masterson hits middle
fuse back the other way challenging Joseph
Smith higher dungeons wide back the other
way goes Greg Giordano trying to get back
Greg fumbled the puck a little bit shot
scores on the rebound and the Ottawa
Senators win it in overtime control
when he crossed the blue line and when
he loses the puck does he get over first
and I think it's good and as he has a look
he just shoots it to the net it's kind of